- Merci, mille mercis!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les tannants!
Pierre Marcotte a connu l'âge
d'or des émissions de variété
au Québec. Durant les années 70
avec les Tannants, c'était
une véritable star à Télé-
Métropole.
DANIELLE OUIMET
Actrice et animatrice
- Il faisait partie de notre
quotidien, il rentrait tous les
jours dans notre salon à travers
la télévision et il faisait rire
les gens. Comment voulez-vous
ne pas l'aimer?
- Né à Joliette le 25 novembre
1938, Pierre Marcotte entame
sa carrière à la radio dès l'âge
de 16 ans. À la télévision,
en plus des tannants, Pierre
Marcotte a coanimé de nombreux
jeux-questionnaires et plusieurs
s de variété.
ROBERT MALTAIS, biographe
- Pierre, il aimait sincèrement
le monde et ça, c'est ça
qui fait la différence entre
quelqu'un qui est connu
et quelqu'un qui devient, entre
guillemets, une vedette,
rée; aimée.
- Passionné de musique, il a eu
deux fils avec des chanteuses.
Ginette Ravel et Shirley
Théroux. Sur sa page Facebook,
rnière souligne:
D'aillees réseaux
sociaux, le réactions
des admirateurs et de la classe
politique on nombreuses. En plus
d'une carrière prolifique
à la radio et à la télévision,
M. Marcotte a été le
gestionnaire de plusieurs
entreprises, dont le restaurant
Hélène de Champlain sur l'île
Ste-Hélène à Montréal. En 2016,
il était monté sur scène avec
la tournnnants, C'est
fou fou fou!" en compagnie
de ses complices de l'époque.
MARTIN LECLERC, producteur
- C'était une personne qui en
donnait beaucoup a son public,
une personne qui aimait beaucoup
son public, qui était
respectueux envers son public
et fort généreux aussi envers
son publson publson publson pub.
- Il devait d'ailleurs faire
un retour sur les planches,
cet automne au Casino
de Montréal, mais la COVID-19
en a décidé autrement.
- Il est mort simplement,
il a fait un Facetime avec
ses deux fils, sa blonde était
à côté et il a dit : "Bon,
on est rendu là." Denise était
dans la chambre, a prisson cellé
de l'oreille de Pierre puis j'ai
dit : Pierre, c'est Robert,
tu es mon ami pour toujours
je t'aime. Et Denise m'a dit,il.
- Avec son décès, c'est
un chapître de l'histoire
de la téui se referme.
- C'est comme si notre passé
et notre époque s'en allaient
avec lui, c'est la mort d'une
époque.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪ ♪